what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and oh my gosh what an ending
for loki episode six the finale of
season one was
absolutely insane and of course before
we go any further i will be talking
about spoilers in this video so
you've been warned after all it is a
finale explained video and breakdown
and after all that we've been through
since the very first
episode of loki we were right about
kang kang was the villain of loki and is
now the big bad of the entire
marvel cinematic multiverse man that
feels good to say it has
officially begun we thought it started
in one division but
now it is 100 happening we are in
the multiverse now there is a ton to
break down of loki episode 6 the finale
of season 1 and i'm probably going to be
doing
many episodes over the next few weeks
but in this video i'm going to be
talking about
every single thing that you need to know
about what happened in the finale
who exactly nathaniel richards aka king
the conqueror aka
he who remains aka amortus i had the
theory about a mortise that i stuck to
and it came true that's the direction
they went and i'll explain
everything that you need to know in this
video and i'll talk about the next
avengers in-game level event how this
sets it up and how this also sets up
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
if you love marvel and want to stay up
to date on everything in the mcu be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos
and if you're new welcome and also thank
you to this awesome community everybody
who joined for the live stream
last night or at any point in time
you're all awesome so let's first start
off by talking about who
the main villain jonathan magers is at
disney's investor day
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios came out and confirmed that
jonathan majors would be playing
kang the conqueror and ant-man and the
wasp quantomania
kang's actual name is nathaniel richards
he actually has many different names
throughout many different points in time
rama tut when he ruled egypt kang the
conqueror when he was conquering
immortus and jerk as he mentions to loki
and silvie
and it's important to know who exactly
nathaniel richards is to understand the
ending
of the loki season finale now he who
remains
actually explains his origin story he
says that a variant of himself in the
31st century lived on earth and
discovered that there were other
universes stacked on top of his
other versions of himself discovered the
same thing in their own universes and
naturally they made contact with each
other
for a while it was good and they
actually helped each other giving each
other their own technology helping other
universes advance
however he explains that not every
version of himself was so pure of heart
and he says to some of us new worlds
only meant one thing
new lands to be conquered and this is
obviously referring to other variants of
him that go by
kang the conqueror of course this
resulted in an all-out multiversal war
between each timeline between each
universe between
each variant and this war continued to
cause tares and the multiverse which in
turn
created a being that existed outside of
space and time and that being was
a lieth the huge cloud creature that we
saw in loki episode 5
the one that loki and sylvia enchanted
with the help of eliath
our nathaniel richards defeated all of
the others he then took the timeline
that the mcu currently exists in
and made it the only timeline the sacred
timeline
and he became the one who remains he who
remains
the only remaining nathaniel richards
and he was afraid of himself he was
afraid of
other variants of him emerging and
coming back and starting another
multiversal war
so he created the tva to stop other
branch timelines from happening to
prevent a huge multiversal war from
breaking out again
nearly destroying everything so in a way
our nathaniel richards
isn't actually a true villain yes he did
some horrible and terrible things to
create the tva and keep the sacred
timeline the only main timeline
but by him doing this is how he
prevented essentially the entire
multiverse from ending
and so we're left with a variant of
nathaniel richards being the creator of
the tva
now our nathaniel richards isn't exactly
king the conqueror although he has said
that he's been called a conqueror
however he could be referring to a
variant of himself one of those variants
that thought to conquer
other spaces and universes instead of
being peaceful
but the nathaniel richards that we saw
in episode 6
is most likely immortus a mortis was
once king the conqueror
however in this story the timekeepers
were indeed
real unlike in the mcu where kang
explains that the timekeepers aren't
real it was all him
he simply made them up and used them to
create the illusion of a bureaucracy but
in his story in the comics the
timekeepers were the last beings in all
of existence
everybody else had died so they went
back in time and they found kang the
conqueror and made a deal with him they
said that instead of conquering
timelines if he would protect them they
would grant him immortality
and kang agreed and he became immortal
and he dubbed himself no longer king
but a mortis and that is essentially
what we saw here
a kang who was actually trying to
preserve
the multiverse a kang that was trying to
prevent other variants of himself from
starting a multiversal war
and also a king that said reincarnation
and he also said that he would just wind
back
up in the same place and right before he
died his final words were
i'll see you soon and then he winked at
sylvie
now there are two ways to interpret this
one is that he was simply referring to
his variants they are him so when he
said i'll see you soon
he could have simply meant a variant of
me we'll see you soon and that could
very easily be the case but let's look a
little bit deeper into what he said
throughout his conversation with loki
and sylvie he specifically said
another multiversal war will start if he
dies and he will just
end right back up here anyways and then
he chuckled
he then would go on to say reincarnation
baby and then
after king said they crossed the
threshold meaning the threshold of the
end of time
what this basically meant was new time
was being written it wasn't at a
standstill anymore and king no longer
knew what was going to happen
more on this in a bit but when he said
we crossed the threshold he then would
go on to say
it feels like a fresh start and perhaps
this was actually
king's plan all along remember he is the
one that gave loki and sylvie the two
options
take his place and rule the tva or kill
him and
essentially cause the multiverse of
madness and infinite kangs would appear
now here's where we dive deeper into
what he said to loki and silvi
loki asked why would he give up control
over the tva over the sacred timeline
and he essentially said
he's tired and he's older than he looks
we have no idea how old he is but kang
is the master of time travel
it's probably safe to assume that he's
lived for thousands and thousands of
years
and as he claimed this game is for the
young
and hungry and that may be true but what
if there was a way for him to return
younger what if he was speaking
literally when he talked about
reincarnation
and ending up back in the same place he
does say that he's been called a
conqueror perhaps he was
actually one of those conquerors after
all kang was a conqueror before becoming
a mortis
it could be the same here but if he was
speaking literally about reincarnation
he could come back
and he could be younger and he could be
hungry again and truly
become kang the conqueror the next big
bad of the marvel
cinematic multiverse the master of time
travel and
seemingly as we have right now the
master of the multiverse and these are
our two
options it could simply be just another
variant of kang coming
or it could literally be him somehow he
could reincarnate himself
and come back but that's something that
we're probably going to deal with in
loki episode 2 or in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness or ant-man and
the wasp quantomania
because one thing is for sure a lot of
kings are coming
and now that you know who nathaniel
richards is we can talk about the ending
of loki episode 6 the season finale and
talk about how kang is coming as the big
bad now as
he who remains explained or as nathaniel
explained
if they killed him essentially the
multiverse would go into madness
branch timelines would be created and
from those other timelines that were
created
other versions of himself would want to
conquer
the multiverse and this would result in
a multiversal war
loki believed kang but sylvie didn't or
perhaps a part of her
did believe but revenge on who created
the tva
got the best of her that was her mission
ever since she was a little girl
she worked her whole entire life to get
to this moment and she wasn't going to
stop she was going to take down the
person
in charge of the tva unfortunately he
who remains
was not lying silvie sent loki back to
the tva
after a good little kiss something that
i think everybody
really wanted to happen whether you
admit that or not and then after she
stabbed loki in the back she stabbed
kang
in the stomach and killed him and right
when she did that the multiverse went
into madness we saw the literal timeline
outside the castle start to branch off
into different timelines
and not only did the sacred timeline
start to have branch timelines but
branch timelines came out of other
branch timelines
this truly is madness and like nathaniel
said there are infinite amounts of
variants of him
that are going to be coming and as we
saw one of them
seems to have already prevailed we go
back to loki at the tva
he is absolutely heartbroken and crushed
from what sylvie did
she betrayed him and she sent the
multiverse into madness
but our loki has changed he's loved and
he
actually has come to love his friends as
well and the universe he immediately
rushes to find mobius he finds him
and immediately expresses how terrified
he is of nathaniel [ __ ]
mobius says at this point how are we
gonna stop it and loki yells we can't
well he actually yells we can't but his
accent is a lot better than me saying it
loki says we made a terrible mistake
he's terrifying he's planned everything
he's seen everything he knows
everything but somebody is coming
countless different versions of a very
dangerous person
and they're all set on war we need to
prepare and here's where things start to
get
really interesting and confusing mobius
who was best friends with loki in the
last episode
and even fought for him in this episode
seemingly no longer knows who loki is
he thinks he's an analyst and he asks
him what division he's from and then he
asks him who he is and what his name is
and then hunter b15 calls in backup she
says boots on the ground now
archives where they are so she doesn't
know him either and just as she calls in
backup
loki immediately notices a new big
statue of he who remains although this
person is most likely
king the conqueror and he has conquered
the tva
and here is where we actually kind of
see the difference between
he who remains and king the conqueror he
who remained seemed to actually be
trying to
save the universe prevent multiversal
war he made up the time keepers and he
tried to keep it pretty simple for the
sake of protecting the sacred timeline
however this king that we now have a
statue for is
not so subtle there are no timekeeper
statues there is no lie about
timekeepers creating the tva in the
sacred timeline
this kang straight up took over the tva
and made himself the god over
them even b15 when talking to mobius
actually references him
she says does he want us to just let
them all branch
he is king the person in charge of the
tva
and this is why mobius and hunter b15
actually don't remember loki
as i'm sure you recall in the original
tba that we've known this entire time
all of the workers are variants although
they did not know that
they thought that they were created by
the timekeepers specifically to work at
the tva but they were
real people before with real lives but
the tva wiped their memories and made
them believe
what they wanted them to believe this is
the same exact thing happening
this specific king has conquered the tva
become their leader and wiped
everybody's memories and made them
believe what he wants them to believe
this is why they have absolutely no
knowledge of who loki is
they have essentially reverted back to
their old state of being brainwashed tva
agents who know nothing else besides
their life at the tva
although this life is them working for
kang now this
king seems to be the next big bad that
we're going to see in the mcu he
controls the tva which essentially means
he controls all of the branch timelines
now whether or not he chooses to wrap
those up and cut them off is entirely up
in the air right now
mobius states that there were 63 new
branches in one unit alone created and
who knows how many units have been
created and judging by the monitor that
we saw in the tva
i counted at least 15 units that were
created
that is a ton of new branches and hunter
b15 states does he want us to just
let them all branch and the way that she
asks this implies that
yes he does and what is his plan right
now we're
unsure it's going to unravel all
throughout phase four but one thing
is for sure this is going to be a
villain unlike any that we've seen
before
a master of time and one that has a
bunch of different
evil variants of himself the new team of
heroes
definitely have their work cut out for
them and speaking of the avengers and
new heroes having their work cut out for
them
this is all going to lead to the next
avengers in-game
level event actually bigger than an
avengers in-game level event
this is all leading to secret wars in
the secret wars
battle world storyline a bunch of
different universes run
into each other it's kind of what like
nathaniel explained happened
a huge multiversal war all these
universes
collide into one into one place from
there all of the heroes fight all of the
bad guys and there are multiple
different
variants of multiple different heroes
multiple variants of iron man multiple
variants of thor
spider-man you get the picture and this
is what is going to happen
in the mcu unfortunately it's not going
to be happening anytime soon i say we're
probably seven to eight years away from
it happening
huge events like avengers infinity war
and avengers in-game don't just happen
every few years or so unfortunately but
when secret wars finally does come out
we're going to be seeing multiple
versions of the avengers multiple
versions of the x-men the fantastic
four all of the heroes that we love are
going to have variants and all of these
variants are going to come together to
fight
the evil variants this also opens it up
for people like robert downey jr and
black widow to return
chris evans can return as steve rogers
because it will be a different version
x-men from the fox universe could return
as well because this won't undo what has
happened in the past because they are
simply
variants from another universe it's
going to be absolutely
insane and this is exactly what loki
just set up
and speaking of people who have their
work cut out for them dr strange
and spider-man are two of those people
now keep in mind that the writer for the
loki series michael waldron
also wrote doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
that is not coincidental and as this
finale came out we got reports that
loki is actually going to end up in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness again not a coincidence
we just witnessed the madness this is
what the multiverse of madness is
referring to
what loki and sylvie just did by killing
he who remains
doctor strange is one of the most
powerful beings in the universe
and he is actually aware of other
universes other realities this is kind
of his specialty
however there is one very important key
to doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and fixing
the multiverse and that is wanda in one
division they hinted at wanda being a
nexus
being in those commercials where they
talked about the nexus pill
then in loki they talked about nexus
events now in the comics
nexus beings are extremely important
they're entities that have the ability
to affect
probability and the future and alter the
flow of the universal time stream
they are the keystones of the multiverse
and are extremely
important to the multiverse's stability
this is why wanda is going to be
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness that and you know she has the
dark hole
and is using extremely powerful sorcery
and witchcraft but wanda and doctor
strange are going to be
two of the main key people that are
going to help restore
the multiverse and make sure that there
isn't a multiversal war again
but there is going to be one that's
going to be secret wars but that is what
loki has set up
for doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and that's what we're going to
be seeing
but before that we're going to get our
fair share of madness and spider-man no
way home
now we know it's going to be a
multiversal film specifically
the spider-verse and if you have much
doubt left
after that season finale of loki then i
don't really know what to tell you
i get it you don't believe it until
there's proof but keep in mind doctor
strange
is in spiderman no way home and alfred
molita and jamie foxx are confirmed to
be in the film as well
both from different universes so
spider-man no way home is going to be
the first film that we actually see
repercussions of what just happened in
the loki finale
loki and sylvie killing he who remains
slash nathaniel richards
created the multiverse now other
variants of
everybody exist and they're going to
continue
to exist there is no longer a tva
focused on killing these branch
timelines and variants
this is how two things happen in
spider-man no way home the first thing
andrew garfield and toby maguire show up
as variants of spider-man
everything in their movies actually
happened they were simply
in other universes and they are variants
of spider-man peter parker
as loki explained variants can be very
similar to one another or
they can be extremely different like one
could be tom hiddleston and the other
could be
an alligator so this is going to bring
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man
on screen with our tom holland
spider-man the second thing it's going
to do is bring
all of these other villains from
different universes into
our universe and essentially the
multiversal war
will begin in spider-man no way home the
branches are going to start to go into
other branches and variants from one
branch will cross over
into others from there on out enters the
sinister six in our main
timeline alfred molina's doc ock jamie
foxx's electro
willem defoe's green goblin and others
that are rumored to pop up as well
so as you can see the finale of loki
season 1 has huge repercussions going
forward in the mcu
from here on out the mcu is never going
to be the same we are now
officially out of the marvel cinematic
universe and into
the marvel cinematic multiverse and
anything is possible now now as i
mentioned
this is just one breakdown of the many
breakdowns that i'll be doing over the
next few weeks about the loki finale and
what it means for the future of the mcu
i hope this breakdown helped you learn a
little bit more about what happened in
that season finale and let me know what
you think about the season finale in the
comments down below
what would you rate this one out of 10.
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest marvel news
don't forget to like the video and again
huge thank you to you all
this community is awesome thanks for
everybody stopping by my live stream you
all make this
absolutely incredible and i love you all
if you want to follow me on twitter and
instagram my links are in the
description
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof